seitdem ich das erste mal gehört habe
dass ich kein mcdonald von einer
büroklammer zu einem haushoch getauscht
hat habe ich mich gefragt ob das
wirklich möglich ist die älter ich wurde
und desto mehr zeit vergeht desto
weniger hatte ich das gefühl dass das
wirklich möglich ist aber warum nicht
eigentlich einfach mal probieren als
rege mich dann vor ein paar tagen
spontan gefragt ob ich nicht mit madeira
fliegen will und ich genau einen euro
auf dem konto hatte sheen mit dass nach
der perfekten option genau das
auszuprobieren wie schwer ist es
innerhalb von fünf tagen aus einem euro
so viel geld zu machen dass man nach
madeira fliegen kann
[Musik]
als allererstes aber ein paar regeln ich
habe fünf tage zeit ich starte mit einem
euro und ich darf arbeiten beim arbeiten
darf ich aber nicht auf bestehende
kontakte zurückgreifen oder irgendwelche
hilfe von freunden annehmen das bedeutet
ich könnte jetzt nicht einfach irgendein
foto auftrag annehmen und das dann
fertig machen aber fotografie könnte
vielleicht noch einmal zum thema werden
in den fünf tagen und natürlich habe ich
mir auch schon ein paar gedanken wie ich
das möglicherweise schaffen könnte zum
einen habe ich auf ihre kleinen anzeigen
dinge gesehen die von leuten verschenkt
werden obwohl sie eigentlich noch super
gut in schuss sind und ein paar euro
wert ich glaube darum kümmere ich mich
als aller erstes mal ich habe dann auf
ebay kleinanzeigen 50 seiten durch
gescrollt wo überall leute produkte im
raum köln zu verschenken hatten und ich
habe natürlich nach sachen gesucht die
ich noch verkaufen kann und da man echt
krasse sachen dabei und nicht nur krasse
sachen die man gut verkaufen kann
sondern auch so dubiose sachen wie das
hier zum beispiel echter führerschein
100 prozent echt haben sie sich gefragt
wie sie ihren führerschein machen sollen
haben sie ihren test gemacht und sie
sind gescheiter wissen sie wie man fährt
aber sie haben keine dokumente um ihr
eigenes auto zu fahren
wir sind hier um alle fragen zu
beantworten weitere clients naja aber
abgesehen davon habe ich sachen gefunden
wie dieses fahrrad was einfach komplett
for free zu verschenken ist und wofür
man definitiv noch ein paar euro
verlangen kann schreibtische
lautsprecher haushaltsgegenstände
einrichtungsgegenstände im prinzip bei
wirklich alles dabei sogar elektronik
den schreibe ich jetzt alle nachricht
und hoffe dass ich die sachen heute noch
abholen kann weil dann könnte ich dir
auch heute direkt einstellen und die
dann natürlich schnellstmöglich
verkaufen und gerade bei so sachen wie
den lautsprechern oder der nähmaschine
bin ich mir super sicher dass es dafür
leute gibt die das kaufen ist in zwei
stunden vergangen wir können zwei sachen
abholen also zwei personen haben mir
geantwortet ich fahre jetzt sofort los
hole die sachen ab und was wird aus bloß
bekommen haben ist völlig verrückt um
seht ihr jetzt
es ist wirklich unglaublich die
allererste sache in diesem experiment
die wir komplett kostenlos bekommen
haben und die uns hoffentlich ein
stückchen näher
manchmal lehrer bringt ist diese alte
kamera ist es eine canon 1 und ich hab
sie komplett kostenlos bekommen weil der
typ der sie abgegeben hat gesagt habe
dass sie kaputt ist das ding ist ich
habe genau die gleiche kamera wie diese
nur in schwarz hier
daher kenne ich ein paar probleme an der
kamera und schon beim abholen habe ich
gesehen was vermutlich das problem ist
die person hat zu mir gesagt dass die
kamera kaputt ist weil sie nicht mehr
auslöst dinge an dieser kamera ist dass
die neue automatik hat und sie nicht
auslöst wenn keine batterie drin ist ich
habe schon als ich da war das
batteriefach aufgemacht gesehen dass
keine batterie drin war
wenn ich also jetzt mal eine
funktionierende batterie aus meiner
kamera hier ein tue und wir sehen dass
sie funktioniert haben wir instant 30
bis 40 euro gemacht wenn sie jemand
kauft film ist geladen
problem ist ich weiß jetzt nicht so
richtig ob ich mich freuen soll oder
nicht weil ich wusste was das problem
ist und ich habe sie nicht gesagt und
habe jetzt kostenlos die kamera von ihm
genommen für gewöhnlich das
wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht aber weil
es hier um das projekt geht freue ich
mich dass die kamera funktioniert und
wir können sie sofort einstellen so
uncool um 2 ist eine in der maschine mir
wurde gesagt dass sie ziemlich sicher
funktionsfähig ist weil die ersten drei
vier jahre alt ist und bei lidl gekauft
wurde
ich habe die seite hier schon offen und
der neue preis ist 140 euro
problem ist ich sehe das projekt gerade
hier so ein bisschen ein stürzen weil
ich halt eigentlich mich von winzigen
beträgen zunächst in winzigen beträgen
hoch rasseln wollte wir haben aber jetzt
am ersten tag schon so einen riesigen
sprung von null auf weiß ich nicht wie
viel gemacht dass wir uns vielleicht
neues ziel setzen müssen ich werde die
sache aber jetzt erst mal einstellen
vernünftige preise dafür finden und dann
haben wir für den ersten tag schon super
viel geschafft wir sehen uns morgen
hoffen dass wir die sachen direkt an den
mann bekommen wir haben für den ersten
tag auf jeden fall schon unfassbar viel
geschafft viele mehr als jemals erwartet
hätte ich probiere jetzt nur noch
vernünftige preise zu finden die
anzeigen einzustellen und die sachen
möglichst schnell loszuwerden und dann
geht's morgen damit weiter dass wir
hoffentlich diese beiden sachen
verkaufen können und das geld in größere
produkte investieren können
so tragen wir mal zwei als aller erstes
werde ich mich jetzt darum kümmern eine
möglichkeit zu finden am jobs
ranzukommen ohne meine kontakte zu
benutzt meine ersten zwei ideen waren
fahrer und online-umfragen
online-umfragen schließlich aber
eigentlich direkt schon aus weil mein
kumpel steven video gemacht hat indem er
sieben tage umfragen getestet hat und
dabei quasi gar nichts herumgekommen ist
also bleibt eigentlich nur noch weiter
ich hätte mir sofort mitmachen wird die
sachen einstellen und schauen was wir in
den nächsten tagen da noch so viele jobs
bekommen wesentlich jetzt gerade frei
war eingerichtet habe ist eine anfrage
für die nähmaschine gekommen und zwar
keine kaufanfrage sondern eine anfrage
ob ich die nähmaschine gegen eine ps4
tauschen will ich habe halt extra zwei
anfragen eingestellt also einmal zum
verkaufen und einmal zum tauschen und
das erscheint mir auf den ersten blick
nach einem super deal ich schreibe jetzt
ein bisschen mit den hunden und her an
schauen was wir daraus machen können und
außerdem hat sich von gestern auf heute
nach ein interessent für die kamera
gemeldet mit dem ich mich jetzt gleich
schon treffen werde das wirklich völlig
verrückt müssen jetzt irgendwie 36
stunden oder so im experiment und sind
schon so krass vorangekommen mal schauen
was jetzt aus zwei wird und ich kümmere
mich jetzt erst mal wieder um über
kleinanzeigen sache also ich bin jetzt
auf den weg ich mich mit dem typen zu
treffen der die kamera von mir kaufen
will ich hoffe der verhandelt nicht zu
krass und ich kann ein bisschen was film
wenn nicht dann sehen wir uns jetzt
sofort wieder so wollen es lief alles
perfekt wir haben unsere ersten 45 euro
und das bedeutet wir sind 45 euro näher
an madeira im endeffekt bin ich super
zufrieden mit dem preis und wir hatten
theoretisch das video auch für 0 euro
nach madeira nennen können weil de facto
habe ich jetzt den einen staat euro gar
nicht gebraucht so 45 euro schön und gut
wir haben allerdings jetzt 17 uhr und
die person von der nähmaschine
beziehungsweise der playstation hat sich
immer noch nicht gemeldet und unser fall
kaum sieht genauso aus perfekt 0
anfragen 0 klicks niemand hat unsere
anzeigen auf halber gesehen
ich werde genau die anzeigen die ich
jetzt auch vorgestellt habe so doppeln
und nochmal auf ebay kleinanzeigen
hochladen in der hoffnung dass da
vielleicht jemand nach einem cutter oder
nach bildbearbeitung sucht naja aber wir
beenden tag 2 mit 45 euro einem
potenziellen tauschangebot was wir
hoffentlich morgen dann durchführen
können und 0 klicks auf unser angebot
so tag nur drei nicht nur hat sich
gerade der typ für 13 uhr angekündigt
denn die playstation gegen die
nähmaschine kaufen will sondern wir
haben auch unsere erste order of five
bekommen in der geht es darum dass wir
bilder für eine website bearbeiten da
kümmere ich mich jetzt sofort um und
sobald ich fertig bin sollte eigentlich
schon der typ vorbeikommen der die
playstation bringt ich bin super
gespannt ob die playstation funktioniert
ob das alles reibungslos geht und ob der
auftrag bei war so durchgeht wie es
geplant hat ich habe für das ganze nicht
mal eine stunde gebraucht und 20 euro
für weniger als eine stunde ist ziemlich
ziemlich gut
außerdem habe ich hier die nähmaschine
schon ready gemacht weil der typ jetzt
gleich kommt und die abholen will
ich bin sehr gespannt was da jetzt raus
wird aber 65 euro auf unserem konto wir
kommen war der immer ein stückchen mehr
was soll ich dazu sagen
ebay kleinanzeigen at its best wir haben
fünf stunden nach vereinbartem termin
und der typ ist natürlich nicht gekommen
also einen tag antwortet er gar nicht am
nächsten tag machen mit termin aus und
zu dem termin erscheint eher nicht das
problem ist wir haben keinen konkreten
zweiten interessenten für die
nähmaschine der typ sagt zwar es würde
ihm leid tun und dass er morgen
rumkommen wollen würde und deswegen im
notfall nicht geklappt hätte
ich glaube aber nicht daran und jetzt
sehe ich das projekt nicht scheitern
weil es so einfach funktioniert sondern
weil wir quasi festhängen ein bisschen
ich habe gerade schon ein bisschen nach
kran besucht den wir für 65 euro kaufen
könnten um ihnen teurer zu verkaufen
aber irgendwie konnte ich in dieser
preisklasse nicht so richtig finden was
mich wirklich überzeugt hat und wir
hängen so ein bisschen an dieser
nähmaschine also die muss weg weil dann
sind wir quasi schon am ziel
dann müsst ihr nur noch einen auftrag
reinkommen und wir hätten alles
geschafft tag 3 geht also zu ende wir
haben 20 euro heute verdient ist okay
aber definitiv nicht das was ich mir
erhofft habe
ob wir es lieben ich hoffe sehr dass den
typen morgen mit der playstation kommt
weil dann haben wir genau noch einen tag
um die playstation loszuwerden wenn er
überhaupt kommt und eigentlich ist das
die einzige möglichkeit wie wir es
schaffen können außer es würden jetzt
noch mal unerwartet zwei aufträge oder
so überfall war oder kleinanzeigen
reinkommen womit ich aber nicht rechnen
bis morgen tag nummer 4 bricht an und
ich habe noch nicht geschaut ob
irgendwas beifall bahrain gekommen
bei kleinanzeigen geantwortet hat
deswegen machen wir das hier das ist die
order von gestern und kein auftrag
perfekt wie soll es auch anders sein
also bleibt unsere letzte chance ebay
kleinanzeigen da schauen wir jetzt
gemeinsam rein und hoffentlich hat der
typ geschrieben der tauschen will okay
finde das ist die rettung irgendjemand
hat mir geschrieben dass er die
nähmaschine für 80 euro kaufen will das
ist zwar 20 prozent weniger als ich
angesetzt hatte aber ich bin super
zufrieden weil das die einzige
möglichkeit ist wie wir aus der
situation herauskommen jetzt muss ich
einfach hoffen dass es wirklich stimmt
dass die person kommt und die andere
person die tauschen wollte hat einfach
gar nicht mehr geschrieben also zwei
stunden warten dann kommt die person und
dann hoffen wir dass sie nicht weiter
verhandelt und die maschine für 80
mitnimmt
der keeper gerade da und hat die
nähmaschine 480 euro gekauft das
bedeutet wir sind insgesamt 325 euro und
symbolisch weil das geld ist noch frei
war
20 euro von faymann das bedeutet
insgesamt 145 euro ich glaub ich gehe
das risiko nicht mehr ein jetzt noch
irgendwas davon zu kaufen und dann
möglicherweise darauf sitzen zu bleiben
ich warte jetzt einfach noch den tag ob
irgendwas überfall war oder ebay
kleinanzeigen reinkommt dann geht es
morgen schon los noch mal der das ist
natürlich keine auftrag mehr
reingekommen
grüß gott freunde wir haben es geschafft
145 euro reichen und haben auch drei
euro übrig um davon irgendetwas zu
machen weil der flug hat 142 euro
gekostet dafür komme hin und wieder
zurück und jetzt sind wir bereits in
materie polnisch auf mich hat das video
gefallen wenn ja lasst ein like oder ein
kommentar da ich freue mich darauf was
ihren mann der alles passieren wird ich
werde mich in den nächsten tagen melden
ich habe crazy sachen vor
wir haben bestimmt eine gute zeit bis
die tage